نعم يعني كما تحدثت خالد قبل قليل دخل
العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني
والملكه رانيا بالاضافه الى العائله
المالكه والامراء والان يتم دخول يعني
المدعوين من
المشهورين
من المفترض ان يكون عدد المدعو
وايضا اخوتها والعائله ايضا
نعم انت تشاهد يعني ما لم اشاهده انا يعني
المشهد امامي كما المشهد امامي نحن نرى
المركبات التي تقل المسؤولين والامراء
الذين يدخلون الى قصر زهران حيث سيتم عقد
قران سمو للعهد الامير
الحسين بن عبد الله على الانسه رجوى وبعد
هذا بعد عقد القران هذا سيتم سيخرج
الامير والامير
والانسه رجوى ضمن الموكب الاحمر وسيجوب
بعض او عدد من شوارع العاصمه عمان اغلقت
هذه
الشوارع منذ الساعه الثالثه بتوقيت عمان
وسيتم اغلاقها الى الساعه السابعه حتى
لضمان وصول الموكب الى قصر الحسينيه سيكون
هناك حيث سيكون هناك حفل الاستقبال
الرئيسي للزعماء والمسؤولين
الاردنيين وحتى غير الاردنيين المدعوين
لهذا الحفل هذا يعني سبق ذلك هذه
الاحتفالات وهذا الاحتفال وهو يوم الزفاف
سبقه عده مناسبات او عده طقوس لهذه
المناسبه رافقتها منها دعوه من العهد
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني لالاف من
الاردنيين من المسؤولين وايضا شملت كافه
شرائح المجتمع الاردني هذا العرس خالد
يعني وكاننا نحضر عرس اردني بتقاليد
اردنيه كنا قد نسينا بعض من تفاصيلها
لانها صراحه
كانت يعني رافقته عده تقاليد العرس
الاردني الذي يعني شاهدناه في كافه
المحافظات ايضا بالاضافه الى
الحفل الكبير الذي اقامه العاهل الاردني
الملكه رانيا دعت لي حفله الحناء ايضا
هناك كان هناك
ما يسمى بحمام العريس عند المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات